all right Ted well can you imagine being
struck by a bullet you likely never even
knew had been fired the 8 news now
investigators uncovering some wild new
details in a shooting that injured a
middle school Security employee last
week yeah the person was struck by the
bullet at Von tobel Middle School near
Charleston and Pecos the gun was fired a
quarter mile away this was the scene
outside the school in the Northeast
Valley Von tobel as well as other
schools in the area all put on lockdown
in the incident that caused grave
concern for parents Educators as well as
the kids there authorities investigating
said the shooting was Gang Related and
that the bullet that struck the school
employee again was fired from a full
quarter mile away this map shows where
police believe that bullet was fired and
where the employee was hit in the hip he
survived the suspect 18-year-old Jesse
Rios is in jail on one hundred thousand
dollars bail